Now the second phase of this algorithm uses this table to construct the output order.
What we're looking to generate is the list of nodes in order, and we computed this before.
We see it over here: 0, 5, 2, 7, 4, 9, 1, 6, 3, 8.
Remember we can get that by using a serial algorithm just to convince ourselves that it's correct.
We start at node 0, its successor is 5, the successor to 5 is 2,
the successor to 2 is 7 and so on.
To generate this answer, each node is going to compute its position in the output list,
and we're going to call that position outpos,
and then when we're done, we can use that position to scatter the node into its proper location in that output list.
So just to understand what outpos is going to look like,
we see that node 0 ends up at location 0 in the output list, so outpos better be 0.
Node 5 ends up at the first location in the output list, so it's going to get outpos equals 1.
Node 2 was next and then node 7, and so on.
So this is what we're trying to compute here.
We're trying to compute outpos.
So when we start this, all we know is that node 0 is in position 0, so we can fill in that outpos right away.
Now that node 0 is calculated where it will end up in the output,
we're going to consider it awake, but all the other nodes are asleep.
A node is awake if it has filled in its value for outpos, otherwise it's asleep.
So now we're going to do several iterations of an algorithm that will eventually wake up all the nodes
and calculate their output positions.
So on each iteration we're going to launch N threads, 1 per element here,
but if a thread is asleep we immediately return from that thread.
Only awake threads do any work at all.
So for the first iteration, node 0 wants to wake up its successor, so how does it find the successor?
Well it can look in this plus 1 array to find its immediate successor,
and so we can immediately see that's node 5.
So where will node number 5 write its output?
That's what we need to fill in here for outpos.
It knows that it's coming after node number 0, right here,
and it knows that it's coming 1 hop past node number 0.
So we can add these 2 values together
to see that node number 5 will write its output to position number 1 in the output array,
and so now we have 2 nodes that are awake: Node 0, node 5.
So now both awake nodes are going to wake up another node
and help those nodes calculate their output position.
So now instead of looking at the immediate successors plus 1,
we're going to look at the next line, plus 2,
and we're going to use this to find the nodes 2 away from each of our awake nodes,
so node 0 is going to wake up node number 2.
So node 0 is going to wake up node number 2,
and so where does node 2 write its output?
Well it'll be the sum of where node 0 is at output location 0, and we know we're 2 hops away,
so when we add those 2 up we know that node 2 will be written to position number 2.
Similarly node 5 is going to wake up the node that's 2 hops away; in this case, node 7.
Where will node 7 write its output?
It knows that it'll start from node number 5 at position number 1,
and then we'll add 2 hops to that and get position number 3.
On the next iteration, we're going to use the next line of the array, the plus 4 array,
and each of the 4 awake nodes from output position 0, 1, 2, and 3
will wake up the node that's 4 hops away.
This will allow us to fill in 4 more values into the outpos array.
Node 4 will get position number 4, node 9 gets position 5, node 1 gets position 6, and node 6 gets position 7,
and the final iteration using the plus 8 array
let's us fill in node 3 as outpos 8 and node 8 as outpos 9.
So the final step is to use outpos to scatter the nodes to their destinations, so let's see how that works.
We're going to start by looking at the first node, and we know that node 0 is going to end up in output position 0.
So we will scatter this 0 to output location 0 and write the 0.
The next node, node number 1, is going to end up in output position 6.
The next node, node 2, will end up directly in output position 2,
and so after we do all of these scatter operations,
we come up with the nodes in the correct order.
So as a function of N how many steps does this take?
Square root of N, log N, N or N squared?